[موسيقى]
جمهوريه اوزوبيس
تلقب بجمهوريه الفنانين وتعني ما وراء
النهر لا يفصلها عن باقي الاحياء سوى نهر
فيلينا
جاءت ولادتها بحي فلينيوس وهو احد الاحياء
الشعبيه بالعاصمه الاتونيه احدى دول
البلطيق على مساحه اقل من كيلو متر واحد
وليس صدفه ان يعلن سكان حي اوزوبيس الشعبي
تاسيس جمهوريتهم في الاول من ابريل يوم
الاحتفال بكذبه نيسان من عام 1997
وهو اليوم الذي يتمزح فيه الناس فيما
بينهم
فجاءت ولاده الجمهوريه
مجرد مزحه
كما لا تحظى هذه الجمهوريه باي اعتراف
دولي
رئيسها مدى الحياه رومث ليلكس كاتبه اغاني
ومخرج سينمائيه
الذي يعمل مترجم للغه الانجليزيه الى
الروسيه واليوانيه وهو ايضا مؤلف موسيقي
وكاتب مسرحيات غنائيه
اذا ربما النهر الذي يفصلنا هو العامل
الجغرافي الذي صنع خصوصيه لسكان هذا الحي
هنا فرحنا نفكر في ما يحسن عمله احد ما
يقترح تشكيله جمهوريه مستقله لا اذكر من
اعتقد ان هادينا خبيرهنا في الفنون
المعاصره تسال البعض ان كانت مزحه لا لم
تكن مزحه عندما ضروره ضروره لتغيير شيء ما